this afternoon we get to meet a little
goat that needs a forever home
his name is boozy he was found running
around the streets of downtown las vegas
this past weekend
he was scared as you can imagine but now
he is doing just fine
hector mejia live at the animal
foundation
where boozy is being cared for right now
i think i see him behind you
hey hector yeah so no one cleaned the
goat so now it's up
and available for adoption allow me to
introduce you to
boozy there he is right there he has a
minor cold right now but he's otherwise
in great health
you know he's been the talk of the town
over the past few days and
he is a little shy but he's very nice
and we now know that the male goat is
believed to be about a year and a half
old this past saturday boozy was spotted
running around the streets of downtown
las vegas some actually thought it was a
ram
well metro police and animal control
came in to try and corral him but
i'm told he gave them a hard time they
finally caught him near
umc on charleston just west of rancho
boozy is now getting the best care here
at the animal foundation
but he needs a permanent home dr joe
jared tells me his future owner needs to
keep in mind
that goats are known to be great escape
artists
they always escape so a goat escaping is
not a big deal
a goat escaping i guess in downtown is
kind of unique
again it just reinforces that you have
to have the right
set up or they will find a way out and
then if they're super scared they're
just going to keep running away
so an ideal home would be a barn type
area with running space
he's shy so he needs someone who will
take the time to make him feel
comfortable with people and other pets
the adoption fee is fifty dollars
the animal foundation says this is a
good example of the
wide variety of animals you can find
here for adoption
many automatically think that this place
is just for dogs and cats
reporting from the animal foundation
hector mejia and boozy
8 news now